Malden District Council collects your
council tax on behalf of our partners in
other public sector organizations
serving Essex including Essex police
Essex County Fire and Rescue service
Essex County Council and local town or
Parish councils
while the amount you pay in council tax
may change from time to time the way it
is divided up stays the same
for every one pound that you pay in
council tax Essex County Council
receives 71 Pence for things like
highways maintenance Social Services
schools and recycling centers
Essex police receives 11 Pence for
policing and Community safety across
Essex
Malden District Council receives 11
Pence for services including bin
collections street cleaning planning
Leisure Services parks and Community
facilities
Essex County Fire and Rescue service
receives four Pence for Fire and Rescue
Services across Essex
local parish and town councils receive
three Pence for things like allotments
benches and Parish signs
we hope this video helps explain what
your council tax is used for
you can find out how much you have to
pay as well as more information about
council tax on our website that
malden.gov dot UK forward slash council
tax